the rectangular hyperbola is a special
hat that look we're gonna have and even
more special one because I'm going to
say a special
so if we take this guy right if we
rotate now this time because I'm on no
went in with the rectangular hyperbola
I'm going to stop saying explained on a
square minus y squared on his bed I'm
just gonna copy a square of the other
side so if we were to take this
hyperbola
if we rotate expert minus y squared
equals a squared PI on 4 or by planning
for ok we will get the familiar
hyperbola that we've actually working
with for years before we touched upon X
petal okay we will get and we write it
into the form this time we will have
this hyperbola XY equal
see square okay now they write C squared
because that value is still a constant
but number one it has to be positive for
this particular one and also it's not a
is different from M okay now this guy
here you may be more familiar with seen
him like this right so this is one on X
and all of his cousins does that make
sense so what you're getting here is
what's the high power you've been going
for a long time just draw a little one
for me so we're going to be in the first
and third quadrants and I can put in my
asymptotes they're not going to be off
here applying for radians they're going
to be shifted onto the coordinate axes
like this
that's kind of funny because we have so
very familiar with this shape and yet I
don't know about you but I still don't
feel like this is similar even though
all I have to do is twist my head a
little bit and you'll see it do you see
it
I just orient your head so that you're
looking at it with this asymptote being
um being upright okay and you'll see the
same a purple it is exactly the same so
the two important things I just want to
take after this is what's the
eccentricity and if you rotate it then
what you get then you can still work out
everything from BC you still work out
all of the different features but it
just looks a bit different because those
form of the equation is suggest every
different to this you still get the same
hyper
okay so let's have a look at this now
take advantage of the fact that I can
rotate my head on this to see this so
that means I should be able to retain my
head on this and see that okay so now is
the right time to add the foci and
directions to our original rectangular
hyperbola where are the foci and
director suit let's see the third
oculars where are they relative to one
of them
yeah good sir because I would usually
say that the foci are at plus or minus
AE comma zero but I know exactly what it
is right it's richer so that's like 1.4
ish so that's where a is and I've got to
be a bit further out all right so on my
diagram I'm guessing it'll be somewhere
like that so I'm going to call that one
s which would be yeah route to a comma
zero and then of course you've got it
son very very
okay now likewise I'm going to have the
director sees where they
they're at our a a a on a write x equals
plus minus a or 3 now one other route to
write 102 is actually number you're also
you've also done with my work they don't
know what is up over here I think it's
zero point 707 from memory just check it
for colors like so I do zero point seven
or seven okay I'm not that I'm trying to
memorize that number I've just seen it
so many times having plugged in one / -
okay
so zero point seven I'm coming in here
approximately so that's x equals a or in
through - and you have
image
okay so now have a look at where those
features are and thinking about how
they're going to relate to here we're
not going to be able to put equations
and actual coordinates on just yet but
we can still work out where physically
are they going to be well here are the
vertices you see that we're that it's
going to be like sort of vertical where
it turns around burning so therefore I'm
going to imagine y equals x as my now
what it's like was it has a name as a
nature
and it's yes it's when you cross over
from one branch to the other
it's the transverse axis so I don't want
to draw a trunk it's gonna make my
diagram very cluttered
just like this one okay but if you
picture y equals x is your trend of
transverse axis there you've got to
travel a little bit further to get to
your first focus yes and then you can
travel a little bit further I'm this way
to get s dashed it's exactly the same
way you've got to come in a little bit
to get the directress ease
that's two questions
like I did my best okay so I'm gonna
call this cuz I don't know its equation
yet but when this is D and this is D -
okay now it's not required but I'm going
to leave it to you as a challenge and
since I'm doing it to you as a challenge
I've gotten yourself up to work out well
if I know everything about this and I
know it's just this guy rotated by plan
for radiant I should be able to work out
exactly where these cornets up and I
should be able to work out exactly what
those equations are shouldn't I mean for
instance just on the face of it notice
how these are off at this angle what
angle is that it's going to be PI on 4
radians right island for because these
were exactly vertical so they're just
gone that way that means their gradient
should be super easy this should both
have a great of negative one okay so
these are no hard equations to determine
okay use a bit of geometry have a think
about caramel it's this transverse axis
here and you should be able to work out
exactly where everything is okay I'm not
gonna bother deriving them because
you're gonna it's the values are going
to change depending on this value here
but it's not difficult so you might as
well give this a shot forward well
considering it was this one is exactly a
block